people with comorbidities
um are far more likely to get sick and
die than those without um of stars of of
covet 19 caused of course by stars kobe
2. and that you know that line that i
just read is directly from our driving
size kovi 2 extinct post that we made a
couple of weeks ago that we've talked
about here
and uh the evidence for that is is all
over the place really um
but one of the papers that does a
remarkable job of
of kind of collating the evidence that
exists is the one that we cited in that
paper and also described at some length
by chris martinson
um of peak prosperity uh in which he
dove into this paper a bit more
for a fair bit for 35 minutes or so so
we'll post the link to
martinson's video as well
and i'll just if you would put this up
for a moment zach this is and i think i
think i've mentioned uh this paper by
name before and then i also couldn't
pronounce uh the first author's first
name companions perhaps
um
published in preventing chronic disease
on the cdc site
or yeah it's not even clear to me
exactly
if it's just on the cdc site or if it's
in a
yeah i guess it is in this preventing
chronic disease
journal so the title is underlying
medical conditions and severe illness
among five hundred forty thousand six
hundred sixty seven adults hospitalized
with coca 19 march 2020 through march
2021
and
the upshot is really as we have said uh
multiple times you are much more likely
to get sick and to have and also
separately
uh to have a very bad outcome from kovid
if you have one or more comorbidities
and but it's not just any comorbidities
and specifically the one that they've
found
being the most predictive of bad
outcomes is obesity
and
and then you know interestingly anxiety
and anxiety disorders is number two and
uh neither the authors nor the paper nor
chris martinson talking about it nor
some of his commenters were suggesting
interesting things um
you know nor i
have you know have anything definitive
to say about that like what might that
be one possibility is that the anxiety
actually comes afterwards um right that
at the point that you're hospitalized uh
for coping then um you were easily
diagnosable with with anxiety so you
know there's a cause and effect issue
um and then there's also a possibility
that
because
people with
a lot of health problems tend to present
as anxious or depressed because of
course they would be and there would be
good reason for them to be that they
would then be diagnosed you know before
ever having covered be diagnosed as
anxious and depressed um and be given um
you know the anti-anxiety or
anti-depression drugs as a result and
that being on one of those things is
enough to get you described as being
anxious or depressed in such a study and
some of those drugs may um also be uh
risk factors uh for for covet as well um
although of course there's one um that
may actually run in the other direction
right yep exactly um but the you know
the fact that you may be like more
likely to get prescribed such things if
you already have a suite of other health
problems because you may have good
reason to have anxiety may mean that
this isn't what it seems and it's
actually about um the presence of a
bunch of other um underlying health
conditions unclear um but uh but you
know the other the other predictive
comorbidities are you know as as you
might expect things like chronic kidney
disease and you know as i said the
number one uh the number one factor that
they found in this over half a million
people is uh obesity
and so as we've said you know in service
of this
why does almost none of the health
messaging around serious sorry scoby2
and
kovid
seem to be about those things that you
can actually take control of yourself
there is so much that we can do with
diet to make us healthier and to bring
bring into alignment with expected
um healthy numbers um are you know
things like our our blood sugar and our
blood pressure and things like this and
obviously the more fit you are the more
active you are
the less likely you are to be obese and
have other underlying health conditions
and
the downside of getting your health in
order is not a downside at all right so
even if these things turned out to be
you know third correlates of something
else and they didn't have direct effects
on cobot you would almost certainly have
greater longevity greater happiness etc
um for having addressed these things
even if it didn't turn out to have
effects on covid which it seems clear
that it would um it clearly would on
other things you know metabolic syndrome
is you know this this scourge uh among
americans now and you know it's not in
non-weird countries this is something
about the modern
the modern lifestyle which includes crap
food and sedentary um sedentary
lifestyles
yeah um and so i was uh in my
conversation uh with
patreon subscribers this morning i was
describing uh that effectively we have a
herd of elephants in the room
and this is one of them the
complete failure to highlight all of the
easy things to do that don't appear to
have a downside that do appear to
contribute to your resistance to covet
and it's it's a very strange reaction
because
on the one hand we are literally at the
point of you know
uh strong-arming people into certain
treatments as we are ignoring other
treatments and it's not like all of the
other treatments are controversial right
the fact is vitamin d is spectacularly
important as you and i had talked about
early in our our series on covid we
talked about extensively the evidence
that vitamin d
is a strong contributor and you know the
way this works probably
if you have sufficient vitamin d there's
no benefit to extra vitamin d as far as
we know but the cost of being deficient
in vitamin d is very very high with
respect to contracting covet i was
actually surprised at how strong the
evidence has grown since the last time i
looked at it and with regard to vitamin
d in particular vitamin d in particular
and i guess the the reason that this is
conspicuous is that we are not
highlighting
either the fact that time spent outside
in the sun is particularly important in
doing away with a deficiency of vitamin
d
but the clock is ticking for those of us
in the northern hemisphere because yes
winter is coming i know you're shaking
your head you're literally shaking your
head but i tried to make it july today
but nonetheless
um this is an obvious intervention with
no downside tremendous upside extremely
inexpensive something people can do you
know without needing to radically alter
their lifestyles and yet for some reason
we are not recommending
and so in this case you're talking about
um taking it sort of prophylactically
but really on an ongoing basis well i
would i would just tell you how i'm
looking at this for myself and for our
family which is i suspect but do not
know that building up vitamin d the most
natural way which is uh with sunlight um
has some holdover effect into winter
there's probably some period of time at
which you've had little enough sun
exposure that you're likely to be
deficient unless you supplement and so
supplementing is um sure to be second
best but nonetheless i'm supplementing
go to some place with sun for a week or
go just if you're if you if you have the
capacity and the luxury and yes right
and if you you know there's also other
things you can do it's not like the sun
doesn't shine uh in the winter in most
places it does and the problem is that
you're dressed up in such a way that you
don't encounter but you can you can
adjust this to an extent and i and i
think and i actually would have to go
back and re-familiarize myself with the
with the research but um because the
winter sun especially the farther from
the equator you are
the winter sun which is you know
december through march in the northern
hemisphere and june through september
and the southern hemisphere is at such a
low angle and therefore coming through
so much more atmosphere yeah um that it
takes much more exposure um to get what
you need and then add to that the fact
that you're much less of your skin is
exposed there's far far fewer hours in
the day when you could possibly be
exposed then it's just actually much
harder and this is you know this is part
of why for instance uh
boy which scandinavians the vikings i
guess who you know famously ate god and
they were not the ones you know they
were the ones who didn't get rickets and
no they didn't know right what the
mechanism of action was and it turns out
you don't need to know the mechanism of
action for it to be a mechanism of
action that works right in fact we've
only recently been aware of mechanisms
of action at this level at all right the
ability to detect them is hard enough
um but it certainly seems
you know
i think there's a very terrible argument
to be made about um you know obesity for
example and that there's some you know
they don't want to fat shame people and
so they're not highlighting that i think
that's an absolutely appalling
justification for not highlighting it
because for one thing if this motivated
people to get uh healthier and to
control their weight it would have you
know collateral health benefits but you
can't even make that argument with
vitamin d
and
um and from the point of view of
you know this is psychologically
stressful for all of us as you point out
there may well be a tie-in with anxiety
that it may be a co-morbidity and that
therefore making you know making hay
while the sun shines getting out doing
activities that you can do easily when
it's not cold outside is good for you it
allows you to socialize in a way that
isn't at least so far as we know at this
point risky with respect
to cove but all of these things are
pointing in the same direction and so
our failure to highlight all of the
simple interventions that you can make
that do seem to work that have
collateral benefits like
you know calming you down improving your
mental health um allowing you to
socialize without uh putting yourself or
others in jeopardy all of these things
point in the same direction and yet they
are conspicuously absent from the advice
right the advice is so narrowly targeted
as to be suspicious
[Music]
you